uh my name is Sam bman freed I'm the CEO
co-founder of FTX at only 30 years old
this guy had an estimated net worth of
26 billion I mean Forbes had already
done an article on him save for Mark
Zuckerberg no one in history has ever
gotten so rich so young Sam is a genius
an effective altruist and he's also the
wealthiest person under 30 in the world
his hair was disheveled his clothes
usually consisted of loose fitting
t-shirts and a pair of shorts you'd see
pictures of him sleeping on bean bags in
his office you trust the guy more when
you see the car he drives he's worth
like20 billion or something mean first
of all his appearance he's only 29 years
old and he typically wears a t-shirt or
a sweatshirt that has the FTX logo on it
khaki shorts he sounds a little bit like
most tech Bros I went to college with
not showering a ton a really messy desk
he was very much the tech nerd genius
stereotype